last semester of college I was like well
this is it
College isn't about being popular it's
about being yourself and finding people
who wouldn't want you to be anyone else
spend time building those relationships
because as an adult you have to try
really hard join as many clubs as
possible because you're not going to
have an opportunity like that outside of
college this is the time where you can
explore and discover your sexuality just
be safe I wish I knew in college to take
more classes that I'm curious and
interested in and the more you take your
time for yourself you'll discover what
you want to do and where you want to go
in life do everything you can in those
four years and if you take five don't
feel bad
definitely do internships in college
like do ten if you can if you graduate
with a certain degree or a certain major
it doesn't necessarily mean that you
have to go into that field don't be
afraid to have crazy ambitious career
goals because if you don't dream that no
one else is going to dream for you
sometimes in college you want people to
be a certain way so you try to change
people you have to try and let go of
that negative energy and just keep the
people in your life who are really
adding to it not detracting from it talk
it out even though it suck because the
sooner you talk about it the sooner the
problems done and then you can focus on
other things just take a deep breath
because there's gonna be a lot bigger
things in life that you're gonna have to
worry about College is not just about
finding what you're good at
career-wise and it's also about finding
yourself when people ask you what your
experience was share it something that I
really got out of college was making
lifelong friends because those will be
the people that will be attending your
wedding in the future and that'll be
there when you need help don't
compromise yourself at your core like
kind of stick to your guns and stay true
to yourself that's the most important
thing if there's something you want to
do and you can have a slither of doubt
just do everything possible because
you're not going to have this chance
again
take your things as they come there is
no rulebook there is no set plan
whatever you think is necessary
just do you
I'm hot